Quick reminder guys
Check the description for a link to our self made seminar
It's a three day hands on training event  where we are going to teach you how to make a living making videos at home
Hey guys I'm Nate welcome back to the King of random
Today we're gonna be trying an experiment that a lot of you have asked to see we're gonna see what happens if we pour molten aluminum
Onto dry ice and the opposite and see what happens if you drop some dry ice into some molten aluminum
We've got our furnace ready to go and we've got a large block of dry ice so let's get some aluminum
Melting and prep our dry ice to see what will happen
This is some of the same aluminum cable that we've used in a previous video. It's a pretty cheap source of fairly high-grade aluminum
Now while our furnace is heating up
I said I also want to prep our block of dry ice and what I'm going to do is take this drill bit and
Try and drill a sort of core hole out of the center of it
I don't want to pour the aluminum on and have it all just flow right off
I really want it to stay in contact with the dry ice
So hopefully I'll be able to make a small well in our block of dry ice that our liquid aluminum can sit in
Let's give it a shot. I've never tried drilling into dry ice before
Hmm it's not quick
All right, I think that is a pretty good
Well that will hold our liquid aluminum nicely
And it's still at least an inch thick below where I've drilled out
So we should have a good insulating layer still our drill bit got nice and cold drilling into our block of dry ice
Looks like our aluminum is just starting to melt inside the crucible now
I think our aluminum is now pretty well molten and before I take it and pour it into our block of dry ice I also
Want to try breaking off a small piece of the dry ice and dropping it down into that aluminum?
I'm not sure how much if at all it will react
I know that regular ice and molten aluminum can have a sort of explosive effect
And I am a little concerned about that with the dry ice as well although
I don't think we'll have that violent of a reaction so our small-scale test of dropping a small piece of dry ice in will involve
Me being able to be away having some containing walls, so if it does splash
I'm not in as much danger and overall. I think it'll just be safer to test it out on that scale first
I've got a small chunk of dry ice let's see what happens if I start by just dropping this little piece into our aluminum
alright dry ice being dropped into molten aluminum 3 2 1
It's just kind of floating on top of it, I've got a few more tiny pieces, I'll drop those in too
I think we are seeing the leidenfrost frost effect in full force
Splash, let's try this with a slightly larger chunk to see if it makes any difference
Well it dropped it and
it fell
in, I dropped from high enough that it actually fell into the aluminum instead of just sitting on top and it made just sort of
one
big bubble
Sitting on the surface of the aluminum. It's not really going anywhere or doing anything
But it looks funny, now I'm gonna poke it.
Oh, it just collapsed it was sort of like an aluminum foil bubble and when I poked it it all just disappeared
Can still see it just floating on the surface there
there we go there's our first test seeing what happens if we put a small chunk of dry ice into the molten aluminum
Now I think it's time. We scale it up and pour a bunch of that molten aluminum down inside our dry ice block
What do you think is gonna happen?
And three two one
That's a cool like
weird bubble on top of the dry ice thing
I like that
We get a lot more emotion pouring the aluminum into the dry ice and then dropping the dry ice into the aluminum
That is bubbling and spurting and splashing all over. I kind of like that
Well, it's cool
It's just kind of floating in there now I think it's
Formed like a very smooth barrier layer between the two
Alright I'm not gonna touch it, but I'm gonna put my hand near it to see if I can feel the heat
If there is any heat coming it yeah, there is plenty of heat coming off of that Wow that is toasty in fact
I mean the dry ice obviously is freezing cold, but right here. There's a lot of warmth coming off of it
See if it would burn this stick at all or anything yep
Touch this stick to it
and it starts smoking pretty quick it might be hard to see in all the fumes and vapors from the dry ice but
Touch the stick to it, and it starts burning still
Still a lot of warmth coming off that though
That's so weird to have my hand this close to dry ice and have it be warming up instead of cooling down
I put her right here
I can feel how cold it is, if I put her right here though. They're still warmth just
Coming up off of that aluminum oh
There we go there's our aluminum ingot that we've now cast in dry ice
Still very toasty, it's been sitting in the dry ice
For several minutes, but it's still hot enough that it's not safe to touch you can actually see that it's starting to
bury its way into the block of dry ice -
Doesn't like that
Well we've still got a divot in our dry ice and we've still got more aluminum in the crucible I say we do it again
Three two one
Whoa, that's exciting
That was cool for a second as I poured it in. It was still glowing orange. Oh
Fun bubbles
It kind of reminds me of in Star Wars
Episode seven when Rey makes her little
powdered food
She like adds the water to it and stir it with her finger and like that muffin grows out of it
It looks kind of like that
Bloop
Oh snap
We've got our camera just the tiny, tiniest bit
So weird it looks like it's solidified
But if I poke it it's still soft the tongs are still able to just stab right down into it
It's like a an
Aluminum paste, but just because it's so hot still
All right, we've still got a little bit of aluminum left in our crucible
So now let's just pour we have left on top of the aluminum. That's already in the dry ice
here goes
Hmm, it's not as exciting when it's not in contact with the dry-ice on all sides
So now it's resting on a bed of warm aluminum instead of touching the dry ice directly, and it's just not very
reactive now
I'm gonna pop the bubble now
Wasn't really popping it was more of just crushing it
heh
It's sort of puddled out as it went down into the dry ice so now our ingot is just stuck
In the block of dry ice
Oh!
We've actually managed to go all the way through
There it is, ha!
So here is our ingot of aluminum that we poured on top of more aluminum
nice
curved round edges to that
And then our dry ice brick
Which we've just melted a hole right through with our aluminum
There we have it a little bit of dry ice dropped into molten aluminum, which wasn't very reactive
But the molten aluminum poured into the dry ice I thought looked really cool
We had a nice little well that I drilled into the dry ice block and that did a really good job of containing the molten
Aluminum I think all of that cold fighting with all of that heat was pretty fun
We had a lot of really good bubbling action it seemed like the aluminum would bubble up
And then maybe it would just get too hot and collapse back down or get too thin walled and just break
But we had a lot of rising and falling of the bubbles in the aluminum, which looked really cool
And we managed to melt a hole all the way through our block of dry ice
We've got a couple of aluminum ingots that we managed to pour into the dry ice block overall this was pretty fun
I didn't know what to expect
I've never poured liquid metal into a block of dry ice before but it turned out pretty well
And it splashed and splattered a little bit
but it wasn't an explosive super dangerous amount of reaction for the most part it just
Spurred it a little bit
and I was wearing thick leather gloves ahead my glasses on I would have long sleeves on and I was able to back away as
Soon as I poured it in so I felt pretty safe the whole time even though a little tiny splash of aluminum
Did jump up and stick to the front of one of our cameras
This was a really fun idea and we tried it because there were a ton of different people who requested it down in the comments
So if you've got a cool experiment you want to see us do let us know down in the comments
And we might just film it
Thanks for joining us for this video today and remember to come gear yourself up with products and merch at thekingofrandom.com
See you there
Kind of stuck
Somehow we have managed to fuse aluminum
To its steel Pan. I don't think that's going out
quick reminder
There is a link down in the description to sign up for our self-made training event if you've been wanting to build a career
From making videos at home doing the things that you love this is how you get started